[Music]
- wine hey everyone what's up welcome to
simulation from your host down sake on
we are sitting down without metameric
what's up it's pleasure to be here Alan
thanks for coming on the show thank you
for having me
I appreciate it and so we are gonna be
talking about data we'll be talking
about storage when are you talking about
systems we're gonna be talking about
general data privacy and be talking
about yeah I know are we talking about
those memory memory yes so give us a
little bit of taste into the last couple
of of years of your research and what
you've been up to and what your
understanding of this is because I'm
super fascinating I'm excited to learn
so I'm probably known as a storage
systems researcher and I teach operating
systems and one of the fun questions
that sometimes comes up is well what
does that mean what does it mean to work
on systems software related to storage
and system software in general and the
rather embarrassing answer is when
people ask well what does your work do
the embarrassing answer is nothing you'd
notice if we're doing it right so but we
kind of do notice as you're doing it
right because doing a good job at
decreasing cost increasing storage
capacity right that kind of stuff so a
large part of that has to do with the
way Hardware develops and technologies
change but a significant part of it is
also how we use it so if somebody were
to tell you to use a car analogy your
car can go a certain distance and can go
at a certain speed but if I [ __ ] with
its software a little bit I can make it
go farther or I can make it go faster
would you attribute that to the software
or would you attribute that to the power
of the engine intuitively we tend to
attribute it to the underlying hardware
we don't generally think about what the
software is doing except that it's oh
it's managing the resources we have as
efficiently as possible and if it's not
doing that then it's wasting our
resources and so we only notice it when
it's doing something bad the equivalent
on the system's end of things is your
computer has a bunch of resources
available to you your storage has volume
to it it has certain performance
characteristics and some of those
characteristics have improved
dramatically over time especially the
volume so if I told you a year ago you'd
be able to buy more than a terabyte for
less than $100 if I told you that a
decade ago you would yeah I thought now
that doesn't sound quite right so what
does it mean to trade speed for capacity
for example if your capacity is cheap
and you've got lots of it and you want
to go out there and call data from
somewhere else
hoarding large quantities of it nearby
on your hard drive is burning space but
it's giving you speed because you don't
have to go out and fetch that data again
so algorithms like that that manage
caching or you see the more in things
like CD ends pushing through the web you
don't have to cross the planet to pull
the same website edn exactly so that's
that's a layer of software where if it
doesn't work you notice and you get
angry at it but when it is working
you don't usually attribute the
performance to it right you actually
taught me about this so you maximize
anticipation of future requests that's
one of the one of the techniques we've
used to improve storage performance so
that's actually a really fun example if
I told you
going to want certain pieces of data in
the future and I'm going to try to
figure out what those pieces of data are
before you want them yeah
now intuitive way to take advantage of
that is to go out and get that data
before before you actually ask for it so
like right now what I'm imagining is I'm
imagining my solid-state drive on my
computer and I'm I'm I'm thinking of my
operating system observing me opening a
folder that has that that will that will
want that that will almost certainly
want me to have certain files easily
accessible and then it going and pulling
the data from the cloud onto the SSD and
then making it easily accessible for me
to use rapidly and then when I'm done
with it
putting it off of the SSD so that's
exactly right on another level of it you
could imagine if that folder is a folder
you keep opening a lot the files on it
don't necessarily have to be left on the
drive they're pulled up into a memory
cache so you don't even access the
drivers oh yeah so that's that's the
intuitive way of trying to improve
performance by figuring out what's gonna
happen else right there but that's being
common in it's been around for four
decades now in in one form or another
what what tends to change is the
techniques we use and how good we get at
figuring out what's gonna happen next
that changes a little bit from time to
time but another way to think about it
and that's that's where I think that's a
really fun example is if you knew all
the future requests that somebody was
going to make what would be the best
thing to do with that information
fetch the data and bring it nearby yeah
that sounds like a good idea but fetch
it from where from a distant place and
bring it close to you well sometimes
that distant place is also nearby but
there's variations in how far away they
are so it might be better for you to not
even bring the data in but to instead
say to yourself
look if I notice that this tends to
happen after that all the time I should
bring those two pieces of data together
and store them in the same place
together so instead of you going out and
saying I'm going to figure out what
you're going to do next and I'm going to
go out and get that data and bring it in
instead you just say no no no no read
your data in bigger chunks and because
I've placed the stuff you're gonna want
next close by just doing that has the
same effect and that actually has a
really fascinating side effect I
apologize from getting to nitty-gritty
here with this but if you consider that
traveling to different locations in
making the requests has a cost totally
does time time and energy perhaps by
doing that colocation by bringing
together the data that will be accessed
together you reduce the number of
operations you do which means that you
would be reducing both time and energy
so going back to the car analogy it's
like me asking you would you like your
car to run faster or go further and then
you tell me I can't decide myself don't
worry about it we can do both by doing
that instead of going out and fetching
from wherever it is and not relocating
things that's one of those cases where
just shifting your perspective how do
you use that information just the way
you use it no change in the information
itself gives you a win win in a
situation that otherwise would have been
considered a trade-off so this is so
good the car analogy is good too and so
is just making this really applicable
for people to understand so let's okay
let me take this back a little bit just
to the very beginning so ok with storage
systems research initially there's
Hardware like a hard drive and there's
the software that writes the ones and
zeros onto the hard drive
and you can really you can optimize both
the software in the hardware so yeah so
optimizing the hardware is something
that storage systems researchers who
specialized in that do I'm more of on
the software affluence so now so now
furthermore is we have the hardware
optimization which is like the engine
and the axis and wheels and these other
components of the car
yes and then we have the software which
is kind of like the computer inside of
the car and so then so then what are
some of the ways in the last decade or
so as you've been in in figuring out how
to maximize the software of writing ones
zeros to the hardware what has been like
an optimizing because we talked about
the anticipating future requests what
other like ones can you bring up for us
so your varied I mean an amazingly good
question there because it goes deeper
than what are the best ways to make
things faster or more efficient
I mean efficiency is always going to be
a big deal because let's put this in
perspective how much data is there
that's oh my god okay it's like every
every what is it it's like in the last
two years there has it's all ninety
percent of all the data that's ever been
made is made in the last few years that
is so that is an amazing way of looking
at it and another way of looking at it
and I'm very cautious about you know
stating numbers on that because the ways
people estimated very rather
dramatically but if you ask me that
question five years ago I would have
been talking about things and the
exabyte ranges per year you know we're
generating extra bytes of new data per
year ask me that now I'll be talking oh
we're talking
satellite ranges and this is just a less
than a decades difference where we're
talking about orders magnitude massively
more amount of data put that in
perspective an exabyte would be today a
few rack enclosures in a data center X
plates a thousand petabytes so sorry let
me let me put that I misspoke there a
petabyte would be a few enclosures
paralyze thousand terabytes petabytes is
yes if let's say a thousand an exabyte
would be a thousand more than that okay
and that is a thousand more than that so
when you talk about a petabyte you can
imagine a petabyte being a couple of
cupboards worth of space an exabyte
you're talking about a fairly
substantial data center like a
four-story building on a city block
right that's that's an exabyte so when
you start talking about is that a byte
though you're talking about some
estimates would be let's take twenty
percent of Manhattan turn it into data
centers maybe we'll have enough room
then phenomenal right Wow
so that leaves you with a certain or the
scale of the of the problem of college
today
oh no per we're talking about satellites
per year so year okay but that's the new
data generated where's the old data
going yeah
we've still got that but the reason to
DNA that's a fascinating thing yeah
because we recently had a very
interesting debate at a at the mass
storage conference between one gentleman
explaining the realities of what it
would cost to build DNA storage today
and another gentleman explaining the
technology trends that might make it
actually feasible in terms of cost so to
put that cost thing in perspective
where's catalog there become
DNA and a twist fire science were wanted
once the ones who make the synthetic DNA
and but forgive me for going back to the
exabytes versus zettabytes
so what's after zettabytes right it's
yottabytes or EOB bytes depending on
which terminology and phrasing you want
to use but if you take an exabyte as 2
to the power 60 the one after the
zettabyte would be 2 to the power 70 so
can you imagine we'd go up to 2 to the
power 80 I'd like to throw that number
out there and say yes maybe we could
imagine that but that would be foolish
of me because if you looked at what that
would take in terms of data centers we
basically have to dedicate a couple of
states to it maybe take Delaware and
Rhode Island and turn them into big data
center farms and then we'd be able to
store yottabyte so there's like data
storage within conventional methods is
not sustainable at all it those are
famous lost words because not that long
ago people were saying the magnetic hard
drive would be long gone and dead by now
but we're still using them because of
cost for capacity so if you're talking
about an order of magnitude greater than
zettabytes you're talking about just the
cost to build the storage is I believe
one estimate something like 30 to 40
times global GDP it's on the order of a
hundred or so trillion dollars so yeah
that's not feasible now and but the
famous last words is when somebody tells
you something's not feasible based on an
estimate like that and something
radically changes in technology that
changes the costs and then they're
proven wrong and foolish but if some of
the software that you've written that
has helped write on to hard drive oh I
wouldn't I wouldn't claim anything so
because well there's something actually
you said a while back which had to do
with educating the public yeah and make
it relatable yeah exactly yeah so so we
do on the show what were things our
label so what's research
all right what's what's the difference
between research and education are they
both scholarship or not and and so one
answer to that one one perspective on
that is size of audience so you're
breaking new ground and discovering
something absolutely nobody's thought of
or seen before who are you educating
yourself at that moment when or verify
those results and share them with the
research community who are you educating
experts in your field who are small
group of people who specialized in that
when you're communicating those research
ideas to a broader community across
disciplines and then to the public who
are you educating a broader audience so
when you think about it everything all
the way up is you're educating so the
reason I mentioned that is I would never
be so pompous as to say my work has
changed something in that way but
because a change you make an idea you
have you demonstrate its feasibility the
way it winds up then being realized lots
of people have contributed to what winds
up being a product we use in our day to
day some more than others some more
directly than others but every little
bit helps
I think but yeah I would never claim
that I've done more than a little bit
and so what have been some of those
little bits of maximizing the writing so
this we got here from your question
regarding what has been done more
recently and what's being done there and
the reason I've taken this rather
roundabout route it's because some of
the problems some of the more serious
problems we're facing now I think have
less to do with what we do with the ones
and zeros and perhaps as much to do with
how we understand what it is we want to
do yeah exactly
so back to the car analogy and also
moving to the
anticipating future requests like we
were talking about as well exactly
exactly
so anticipating whose future requests so
this is the user above the application
above the way it's accessing the data so
the patterns of future requests you see
are driven by some logic some particular
goal now what if that goal or that
implementation or that application isn't
properly optimized for the underlying
storage technology so I'll give you a
heartbreaking example and it truly is a
heartbreaking well it's heartbreaking
for me perhaps that's a little too geeky
that is the best way to be why indeed so
so let's take for example most storage
devices work on a model whereby you
specify the location and you store the
data then you provide that location you
get the data back from that location yes
so what if I told you that there is a
magical device where you could present
it with your data and it tells you where
it is hmm that's cool or alternatively
tell it where you want to look and it
tells you what data is there now imagine
a device that could do that in a flash
literally in a flash now what I'm
describing isn't sci-fi speculative food
it's basically how a holographic data
storage device could work okay a
holographic data storage device
amazingly exciting technology
immediately brings people to mind of
thinking of what you mean like data
crystals on Babylon 5 yeah exactly like
that but not exactly like that
and so we this does not exist yet a
holographic data storage ah so here's
the thing the technology does an ecology
has been around for actually a decade or
two now at least and it's feasible and
it works and it has some really
fascinating properties one of which is
what I just described you can access the
data by its content and
get the locations where it's stored back
or give the location and get the IDS
stored back if you do that in with
current hardware that's an expensive
thing to do
so there are circuitry in your computer
that works like that and it's expensive
and when I say expensive I mean it's
expensive in that it takes up space and
thereby is expensive it so you can't
most people can't really envision that
being used for a mass storage device a
device that stores a lot of data so to
clarify the way you would store a
hologram is it's an interference pattern
between two beams of light so if you
make one beam of light have a certain
structure to it that represents your
data and the way you do that could be as
simple as running it through a broken
LCD but basically a grid that has pixels
on/off on/off then you create a bitmap
focus that at one point then you use the
second beam that's your reference beam
that becomes your address polarized set
it at a particular angle the amazingly
cool thing about that is you're storing
data in a particular location in that
crystal based on that angle adjust that
angle you're storing in a different
location a different location different
location but the word location is
physically the same spot so that's a lot
of data in one place right
so these had different angles in the
same look exactly because you'd have to
shine the reference beam at the same
angle to get the data that you stored
there same angle yeah okay
so there's like an infinite amount of
angles well a lot is a lot I wouldn't
say infinite because it's it's bounded
by our ability to adjust the resolution
and get a new one yes and and there's
also a limit on the physical property
what's actually gonna wind up being
recorded so yeah parts of it are on the
nature of the crystal parts of it are on
the nature of how precisely you can
control the light there's a lot of
factors that go into it but that way
because the crystal is what's is what
we're shooting light through to angle it
exactly well well the crystal is what
winds up storing that pattern it would
be something like
a substance like m9 bait would be yeah
that's one possibility but but the point
of it is this technology's been around
for a couple of decades right so decades
so why don't we have it why don't I have
a laptop with a data crystal thing why
don't I have a reader that I plop in a
little crystalline cube and draw out
massive volumes of data from it it's
still incredibly hard to read and write
to it I wish that were it what is it
what's the issue I said this is
heartbreaking there was a device based
on this technology that you could buy
and the form it took it was I believe it
was called the Terra disk but I could be
wrong about the name was from a company
called in-phase it was basically a super
dense writable optical disc now when you
think about that for a second you
realize hang on you're telling me
something that had these cool properties
where you could look up the data just by
presenting and get its location back
because think about what that does for
you it makes storage like it completely
agnostic it doesn't matter where you
store because you just present and you
get it back yes but one of the questions
you one of the things you do when with
storage is you look for things right
you've got a database you want to look
for things in it usually to look for
things you would have to have some sort
of a structure that you follow that's
optimized for quickly searching but how
quickly you'd still have to search here
you would say here's my data oh that's
where it is perfect get me the rest of
the stuff that's in that location super
amazing right sounds revolutionary
sounds like it would change everything
except that's part of the problem it
would have changed everything in the
sense of you'd have had to rewrite a lot
of the software built atop of your
storage system you would have had to
have people come up with applications
that would exploit that particular
property and there would have to be
enough of them to justify the cost of
porting decade's worth of legacy
software that it's built around this
particular model of using storage and
having people change the way they do
things and the cost of that wasn't
justified by the coolness of the tack
it's it's an odd it's an odd situation
where your tech has to be so cool that
the applications that it could both can
clearly mean to be worth it that people
would then invest enough money to change
the way they do everything is a
holographic is a storage for data the
future I would love to say yes but I
would have to say probably not and so
the storage is probably DNA this is
probably the future so I'm very cautious
about making predictions yeah and it
would depend on what you mean by the
future so what is the present
solid-state drives or magnetic drives
the answer would be pretty solid solid
state yeah because that's well that's
from one perspective from the
perspective of what it would install in
your laptop what it is you'd have on
your computer yeah but if we asked about
in terms of total volume of data stored
oh yeah what's the present it's magnetic
yeah because the bulk of our data is cat
videos on YouTube and photos on videos
on Facebook right or things like that
and those are winding up in data centers
they're going to be on magnetic storage
just for the cost for those systems so
Wow so when you ask what's the future
I'm loathe to say yeah sure it'll be DNA
the answer is I honestly don't know it
depends sorry I couldn't help it smiling
because the answer to almost any systems
question is it depends
kind of like economists on the one hand
but on the other and that's all that's
good because then that means that you
have nuance you have multi variability
to your answer rather than binary
although it does seem as though
the very far future it would be great to
have DNA as the indoor substrate the
potential for massive capacity in a
compact space is tremendous with DNA
stores and even read/write speeds could
get fast enough yeah so the reading I
get that the writing I don't know how
fast that that's gonna be but but you
see all these questions they're
contingent upon how these technologies
will develop but they're not solely
dependent on that they're also dependent
on us on what we embrace and what
applications will be important and
thereby poor enough money and to make a
new technology take off so how and when
the technology becomes realized is as
much dependent on the human element as
it is on the hardware end of it the
system software is in the middle between
those two levels and going back to the
car analogy predicting what the driver
wants to do might just be as important
as predicting what the engines gonna be
able to do yeah correct so and that's
exactly what this this retrieval is kind
of doing right now a lot of that it's
like what is the driver trying to to do
with the data how can we optimize their
their quick ability to go and retrieve
it but it's also about representation as
well as retrieval all right so yeah
representation a lot of people will take
for granted my data will be stored on
this device what form will it take ones
and zeroes yes yes
how are those ones and zeroes realized
well
magnetic discs will do it one way CDs do
it another flash drives will do it
another way but it's ones and zeroes
right yeah but it's one since zero is
representing what no mass curves of
video data how you encode them is just
as important as how you wind up storing
them and has it has an impact on how you
wind up storing them another example
could be actually the the more
unintended ones like I'm going to try to
restrict your ability to record certain
things and the way I'm going to do that
is I'm going to say you'd better not
write any texts that say something bad
about me but because I'm this terrifying
authority and I'm and I tell you I'm
about to impose this law upon you that
says you cannot write something bad
about me if I find you've written
something bad about me you're in trouble
now the question then becomes how have
you written that something bad about me
so one of one of the most hilarious
examples of that would be if let's say I
decided to write a bad thing about this
person but I did it through my
charitable donations how could I do that
the answer is I will make a sequence of
charitable donations that I will
document and when you look up the
sequence of my charitable donations the
amounts will correspond to different
letters this is cryptography now in a
sense it's it's it's kind of like key
under the under the doormat good but not
real but but it had that issue of it is
difficult to both control and anticipate
how you would represent it yeah yeah so
when some
when somebody tries to outlaw your
ability to record certain things there's
a certain element of unenforceability
about that on the technical end of it
but on the other end of it there's also
a certain difficulty in anticipating
what the best way and what the possible
ways are to represent data the the
charitable donations example is a little
silly but it's you could imagine what's
the best format for you to store your
data and how does everyone get into a
universal way of deciding to represent
their data a certain way and then that
can help maximize the way that we
retrieve that that data exactly so one
of the problems with managing storage
systems is making sure people can get
access to their data in the future right
let's make them reliable so what what do
people worry about when they think about
reliability a toddler spilling a soap on
an on your on your nas box right that
that that's oh I got something bad just
happened or a hard drive failing or oops
I dropped my laptop you think about
physical damage to individual devices
right what tends to not be as well
thought of and that's where the
archiving community is super
underappreciated in my opinion is
looking at things like imagine losing
your data because you no longer have
either the software or the physical
hardware device that reads the medium
that it's on that sounds like a
ridiculous situation to be in
yeah because we for example we Ron's got
a VHS player in the back so he's got a
bunch of cassettes and he's got a bunch
of older equipment back there so he
could potentially lose data because we
no longer have the hardware that is
needed to read exactly does anyone still
have their zip disc readers for example
people were using those for backup -
like crazy and yeah or even CDs nobody
even has optical drives anymore oh so
there was the
exactly optical drives are a little
rarer but there was the funny thing
about CDs when when they first became
especially kids today it's today
everything's gonna be in the cloud
oh I mean what are they even gonna use
that's hardware except their computers
and their smartphones it's hard to even
imagine them having these like thumb
drives or or really anything that's kind
of like that so that's an example of why
I'm really cautious about making
predictions I honestly believe CDs would
lasted longer than they did the the way
iTunes and streaming services
white-white wiped out their popularity
so quickly that I did not see coming at
all yeah the streaming services like
even you know it's interesting how
Netflix was such a quick transition
themselves from sending the CDs to the
home to streaming themselves I mean they
save their ass they wiped out
Blockbuster and they save their own ass
yeah so interesting I mean I'm not sure
do they even still have the DVD service
I think they still do they still do some
but I have to think about it right and
that's indicative of how quickly that
transition has happened okay so we've
okay so now I want to transition us to
memory because this and how this applies
to humans as well because this is
another field of what what you message
me that I thought was so interesting so
like dive us into this okay so again I
don't think I've ever fully answered
your question about what I've been doing
more recently and and the truth is it's
more focusing on the human elements of
interacting with the data storage as
well yeah so and hence comes the
question of memory there's a lot of talk
now about the tension between free
speech view of how we deal with data and
how it's kept and a the right to be
forgotten view and and some critics are
kind of harsh on the right to be
forgotten they'll say
that's the silly idea how dare you allow
somebody to tell me what I can save
about them and this is like if you
ordered a taco at 2 p.m. on Tuesday
what's the point of keeping it on the
blockchain err in the data set like who
cares that you ordered your taco a - now
is it important for your health records
or etc it might be exactly okay so so
but so the the the perspective of a user
who's worried about how their data is
going to be used it's understandable
that they'd worry and they'd want
certain protections because they think
well I don't want Big Brother tracking
what I'm doing right so that sounds like
part of it but it actually comes from a
slightly older place than that it comes
from a principle in French law I believe
which let's say you have committed a
crime and you had been punished for it
is it just for me to hold that over you
for the rest of your life and punish you
repeatedly now how am i punishing you by
bringing it up all the time yeah is that
is that cool is that okay well I hope
that the behavior changes and there's a
community of people around that helps
change helps the behavior change in the
person because then it's much less so
that people hold it over it's like oh
the person has changed so our justice
system had a certain our justice system
had a certain punishment and you have
paid it and you have done nothing wrong
since then yeah when you have paid that
that that price in full is it just to
punish you further now now if you if you
feel things like once people have done
their time they shouldn't be denied
voting rights and things like that then
you're you're of the mind that no that
is unjust and if you are of that mind
then well that's where the right to be
forgotten originally comes from this
idea that you have the right
once you've
paid for whatever transgression it was
to not have that held against you the
memory of it not be used against you
right so you look at that and it sounds
like I'm defending gdpr on the right to
be forgotten at this point but there's
the dark side to it which is this idea
of how dare you tell me what I can and
cannot remember yeah and and that's a
very problematic tension because this
now we're going into opinion not fact
and in my view the way we use data
storage is effectively an augmentation
of our memories and if it is as such
yeah then restricting what I can and
cannot remember seems obscene it seems a
violation of the most personal kind yeah
I'm reaching into your mind and telling
you no no don't think about that that's
that's worse than telling me what I can
and cannot say you're you're policing my
conscience in my private thoughts is
that acceptable no but at the same time
I just made the argument that it's
perfectly acceptable to not hold the
memory of people's transgressions
against them beyond a reasonable limit
so well so here's the thing one way to
reconcile that conundrum is to
distinguish between the act of
remembering in the act of communicating
a memory uh-huh if you can remember but
the moment that you communicate it and
hold it over someone exactly oh the
moment I use it in a way against someone
yeah that becomes the objectionable
thing so trying to deal with it by
simply telling people well you cannot
remember and I'm grossly oversimplifying
the issues here but there's a lot of
really smart people who put a lot of
thought on both ends yes yeah so yeah
definitely but my own personal view is
that it is a question of memory and it
also gets to things like privacy rights
with regards to your cell phones
if I tell you look let me take a look at
your phone and you say no and say what
you got to hide let me look at your
phone what am I doing here am I simply
checking on your phone communications
the answer is of course not your modern
phone tells me where you've been it
tells me who your friends are
it tells me what you wanted to remember
it tells me what engagements you've got
coming up it is a super-sized version of
the private papers of John Wilkes right
which which was the whole reason we have
a Fourth Amendment in the first place
was was a lawsuit before we were a
republic where a leaflet was written
insulting the king right and so general
warrant was used to find out who had
written it and so people's homes were
searched their papers rifle by agents of
the the crown and this this guy John
Wilkes was found to have written it and
so he sued the crown for violating
basically violating his conscience was
what that found of being and he won so
this was before the United States was a
republic this was a time when when we're
still colonies and and now we face the
same thing I know it's the same question
but when we're talking about something
that is even more personal than your
private papers because your private
papers are what you consciously write
down your phone includes things that you
don't consciously include in there but
are of growing necessity to your daily
life so as an invasion it's even worse
it's it's not a Fourth Amendment
violation and search when you do that it
gets to the point of being a and a
compelled testimony in fact the that
court case that was the Wilks case
I may be quoting the wrong one there I
do apologize I'm not a lawyer so forgive
me if my knowledge of the particular
case laws a little off but one of the
comments that was made in defense of the
ruling was either in that case where a
later one was that to hold the person's
private writings against them was as
obscene as holding their thoughts
against them yeah and to take them
without without permission like that or
without cause yeah without what without
a specific warrant for it was equivalent
to forcing a person's conscience to
testify against them yeah now that was
way before we had cell phones that knew
so much about us so when we look at a
cell phone today the way we treat the
data on it honestly needs to be more
respectful of it as if you're appearing
into someone's mind not as if you are
you're searching somebody's private
papers and then so issues surrounding
what we can technically do to make
questions like that more forefront it so
there's like how you called it the
augmentation right of humanity it's our
augmentation it's making us better we're
storing all this useful data on it but
then it's also kind of as an
augmentation of our mind then when
people are aiming to observe that data
they are then peering into our mind yes
and so then the when you ask me the
question like can I look at your phone
right so then the question is you know
you have nothing to hide right and it's
like okay yeah I have nothing to hide
look at my phone the idea is that you
can then see all of the data but then
the moment that you choose to use that
data against me or even beneficially you
can use that data for me by saying Alan
I've seen that you've been going to this
destination every day the last couple of
days would you like me to call you an
uber to
destination or would you like the
certain order of this service because
you've been doing it over and over again
so if they're using the data to benefit
me then it's not about they got a bad
thing
well you skip over a point there which
was the peering into your mind part
that's a big one so so yes so so I
appear into your mind in order to offer
you helpful suggestions and then is it
okay which of those acts is the problem
now the offering the helpful suggestions
is not a problem on its face but the
peering into your mind without telling
you that's a problem and that's an act
click on the accept terms and conditions
button which is saying ok you can peer
into my mind and in that case who's
whose fault is that now the answer is
partially all of us not just the
provider we haven't quite created the
ideal collaboration between the
technology engineers designers and
business as well as the consumer of that
as well as how the data works with that
as well as how they get money from that
and we get money from that data who owns
that so that that whole ecosystem is
going to take an interesting next couple
of years of decade or so let's see what
happened let's not forget information
education and communication so when you
accept when you read the terms and
conditions and accept them how many
people honestly understand them all how
many people actually read them probably
for the first of every couple thousand
ten thousand probably actually no you
did less disease by the timer
oh dear on so yes so the peering into
the mind part is the act without
permission it's the actual events of the
most important things that you've been
learning so uses appearing into the mind
this is the most important problem
without permission but we give the
permission we give the permission but do
we give do we give knowing consent
so the way some terms and conditions
work the answer is maybe not entirely
now is that the fault of the provider of
the service or is that the fault of the
consumer of the service not being better
educated is it do both of them have to
meet each other halfway perhaps or some
way definitely do we have to write that
in big bold capital letters like as the
only sentence at the very top is you
give us permission to peer into your
mind to make your life easier
no mind-melds without permission right
well that's part of it right but the
part of it is the peering in the and the
remembering is a separate thing right
because it's related but it's not the
same so I look into your mind I can look
at what you've remembered now what about
what you consciously remember am I
allowed to regulate that now that's a
huge problem because the attempts to do
that are a form of censorship that is
unbelievably invasive and potentially
very creepy but it's also possibly
unenforceable right I'm not going to let
you remember this one detail that it
brings to mind those arguments about
when when the fans of digital rights
management were were attempted to
copyright a number at one point it was
like ridiculous
right but at the same time what what it
demonstrated was how many ways you could
get around sharing that number it's like
you know what okay
I'm not allowed to share that number
okay how about that number minus one
plus one I haven't shared that number
have I have I so
there's the enforceability aspect of it
but the question is there's also the the
obscenity of attempting to enforce
something like that it is so you say
that if we start treating data as
memories and making it more clear that
this isn't augmentation it's an
appendage it's in addition to humanity
our devices and our data then if we
treat that data as memory and we make
this general data and privacy rights
moral about piercing our memory then I
think the whole conversation will be
shifted towards a more like a ha mmm but
let's take this a little bit more
seriously because this is their memory
this isn't just data in memory exactly I
would say it's not that we should treat
it as such it's that more people should
understand it as such understand it
because lots of very smart people are
being grappling with the ethical
questions around how we manage data and
how we deal with data I mean just the
way that you're describing this right
now I'm starting to think of everything
differently so my phone call log my
texting my calendar my email my
everything on my phone is memory as in
its the memory trail of what I've done
so I can look back and see who I've
texted when I texted them at what time
I'm not viewing that as data anymore I'm
at the same time I am viewing it as data
but I am viewing it more so as memory
and therefore it's like somebody going
into who is Alan how many times did they
message this person at what time where
were they at these times and so that
becomes a serious thing because what is
data if not recalled right and what are
memories is also not recalled yeah
because that's like the fallen tree in
the forest if the data's not were called
at any time then does the data even
exist if it's never recalled yes
if it's never touched if it's never ever
read again ever yeah yeah then what
difference was make if it was or was not
there yeah so then where does where does
I guess a quick question before we ask
you some of the questions that we
typically ask on the show and I'll segue
into the questions we asked on the show
by asking you a question that we have
asked people on the show of a similar
field as you which is that what are we
what's kind of like gonna happen as
easier in your best approximation as we
kind of transition to a world of more
globalization and more open source
hopefully less nationalism more
globalism less individual privacy and
more openness more open source maybe
through technologies like blockchain
maybe we can get there now and a very
strong cryptography in the case of
malevolent players where do you kind of
see that whole mix of data and where
we're going with accessibility to that
data as needed accessibility to the
memory as needed oh boy so that is an
amazing question the if I may rephrase
it slightly yes what's going to happen
as we grow more connected yeah well
because being able to peer into
someone's mind also almost literally in
some cases is ever-growing right our
ability to share our ideas and thoughts
across distances and across time is
increasing that makes us more connected
both over space and time yes so
the inevitability of being good
neighbors the inevitability of the
importance of being good neighbors to
each other on the individual level and
in a more global level that's never
gonna go away it's just going to become
more important the more able we are to
reach more people and the more able we
are to form more distributed yet more
insular tribes that's a problem and the
way to deal with it in a way whether
technologies that help with that or
whether it's through our own
understanding of how we interact with
technology has to take that into account
what it ultimately boils down to is what
kind of a neighbor are you what kind of
a do you feel a part of the society or
not and how much a lot of our problems
go into this application of labels Oh so
as an example forgive me for this rather
random story British comedic writer and
performer John Finnemore wrote a comedy
sketch once where a man sits down and
starts declaring his intent to eat a
delicious banana the woman next to him
then responds that's disgusting
surely you'd rather eat olives because
they're delicious but bananas are ache
and and he then goes on to defend the
banana and then she argues back with him
and after a back-and-forth he proceeds
to eat the banana at which point she
says what are you doing why are you I
thought you were gonna eat a banana why
are you eating an olive so at the end of
that scale it was a radio comedy sketch
you're left not knowing whether the man
was eating a banana or an olive but
you're left with a very clear impression
that they both had applied different
labels to the exact same
thing right so when you talk about data
storage one one layer of the software
that goes over there is all the data
that represents the data that you are
holding so the most common example of
that is your file system which gives
names to individual data objects and
some file systems are better than others
that giving multiple names to the same
thing but if we don't if we're not
careful about the language and what we
mean by what we say we can easily wind
up miscommunicating what it is we mean
so when you see tribalism against the
nationalism fighting against globalism
very often you'll see somebody saying
well that person's bad because they're a
member of Team X but I'm a member of
Team Y team y is the good team when what
they really mean as I think label Y
applies to goodness and the other person
thinks label X applies to goodness and
they don't really disagree on what they
think they disagree so where do I think
all that's heading the better
communication the better education means
we'll we should be embracing technology
in a more effective and ethical and
efficient way on a more global scale
that's like what you do on a micro scale
when you're talking about system
software storage system stuffed we're
managing things more effectively yeah
sorry put that in there and in our path
to get there there's gonna be a lot of
chaos and there's gonna be there's gonna
be a lot of these mishaps that occur and
hopefully they don't inflict a lot of
suffering on to us along the way well
hopefully hopefully not too much
hopefully I have a - people being
ultimately awesome in the end I really
enjoy how my mind's been expanded to
understanding data as a memory and
they're like peering into the mind of
someone that's kind of now what it feels
like it's now I just I really appreciate
the way that my mind shifted in that
sense and and I hope that same things
apply to a lot of people have been
viewing ok a couple questions on our way
out that are related to what we asked
our guests on our show the first
question is what is the most beautiful
thing in the world
everything you see in the glass in your
mind
everything you see in the glass in your
mind no and that lasts in your own
everything that we see and lasts in your
mind every experience and every pretty
much every breath in every moment so
from the moment you're born to the
moment you die everything you experience
yeah I mean the fact that you get to do
that if I forget to do that yes that you
were how lucky are we this hot business
yeah yeah I mean there's the problem of
evil right and that's
that's not a beautiful thing right
ugliness and pain and suffering are
things we must all try to ensure that
there's less love in the world but the
fact that overall I think people tend to
be on the side of minimizing that
regardless of how they might express
that desire and how I might
misunderstand that desire and others
that is a beautiful thing so the fact
that we get to be a part of that so
that's of course birth to death all the
experiences in between most beautiful
things
how about do you think we're alone in
the cosmos oh dear that is a tough one
I think we we worry too much about
seeking another that meets our
definition of what another is when there
are so many others that we do well to
better better communicate with right now
or better understand right now whether
it's others in terms of other people or
other perspectives or whether it's
others in terms of getting a better
understanding of our world around us so
the short answer is I don't know I'm
comfortable not knowing and being amazed
one way or the other should should we be
able to figure it out but in the
meanwhile I'd say rather than the
moaning the lack of encountering
something wondrous out there
it's a good idea to not overlook the
number of wondrous things we encounter
out here - yeah sort that sounds a
little trite but I'm not saying let's
not explore I'm saying let's do it let's
but let's keep our eyes open to all the
Wonder and beauty around us right now
that's good yeah it's a good memory to
bring back our attention to the beauty
of the body and the environment
community that everything we have here
as well all right how about do you think
we're in a computer simulation oh dear
are we in a computer simulation to delay
look there's you there's me a moment ago
in a moment ago and ago we're looking
into the past so that's another one of
those questions where I do not know I
would rather have a better understanding
of what we mean by being in a computer
simulation before ever answering a
question like that maybe we just give a
quick then a quick just being able to
compute well what one of my favorite
life and all well one of my favorite
authors Douglas Adams right remember the
the plot of the hikers guide to the
galaxy you wound up in I believe the
third volume revealing that the earth
was a computer meant to calculate
something so I'm part of a simulation oh
no we might actually be the tip the
electrons in the chip right oh yeah I
just see how the human experiment
unfolds exactly
so are we in a part of a computer
simulation for some definition of a
computer simulation probably yes
I can always get out of it by redefining
the terms yeah
labels matter they do they do I feel so
like the way that I was understanding
things before has now changed because of
our conversation and it feels really
good like I feel very empowered because
of that it's wonderful yeah so god I
wasn't a corrupting or disheartening
influence not at all not at all quite
the contrary it was uh I think that the
way to understand the data as a memory
it changes the way we perceive the way
we engage with our devices and then it
changes the way that we think about data
privacy memory privacy as well as memory
accessibility how quickly we can access
these memories as well as the
architecture of the hardware the
architecture of the software how to
access them quickly how quickly we can
pull them up but also with the memory
when can we give that memory to other
corporations or businesses or entities
that they can then make our lives better
by having access to that so it's this
whole big mix we're gonna be using
digital data in DNA hopefully in the
future for storage substrate rather than
these massive like you are saying these
hopefully one day yottabytes of hundred
trillion dollars worth of magnetic disk
spinning right that's a little bit
insane so this is it's a huge field that
is you know data memory systems storage
all of this and thank you so much for
coming on the show and teaching us about
this thank you for having me and I hope
I haven't been to Android
not at all this has been such a pleasure
thank the question I don't think thank
you and thanks everyone for tuning in if
you guys had a good time make sure they
give us subscribe join the family
give us a comment below with your
thoughts make sure to take some of the
content that you've learned from here
and share it with other people as in go
ahead and make a blog post about it go
make a video about it go write something
about a teacher to other people we'd
love to maybe start a company about it
there's so many cool things that do go
create don't just consume go create with
it
join us on patreon help us sustain the
studio help us sustain the project keep
growing it we'd love to have you join us
thanks for joining us on it thank you
thank you how greatly appreciate it Ron
Vargas a producing director thank you
very much and we'll see you guys soon
peace
you